>> Jesse: AUTHORITIES ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENED, DEMOCRATS AND THE
MEDIA WILL WASTING NO TIME TO
TURN THE TRAGEDY POLITICAL PER
THE USUAL SUSPECTS MOCKING
REPUBLICAN IDEAS TO HARDEN
SCHOOLS AND FOCUS ON MENTAL
HEALTH.
>> PLEASE SPARE ME THE DON'T
POLITICIZE THIS B.S.
THE HELL TO ANYBODY WHO SAYS
DON'T POLITICIZE THIS.
>> IT'S TIME TO REPEAL THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT.
WHY NOT?
>> A GUY CALLED BEDDOE, THESE
SICK OF A BITCH.
THE
SICK >> AN ABSOLUTE FRAUD THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS IS.
NO AMOUNT OF BLOODSHED SEEMS TO
BE ENOUGH FOR MAGA REPUBLICANS.
HE >> Jesse: IT SEEMS LIKE A
LOT OF THE CONSERVATIVE
COMMENTATORS AND CONSERVATIVE
POLITICIANS HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT SOLUTIONS.
THE DEMOCRATS ON THE LEFT WING
MEDIA HAVE BEEN ATTACKING
REPUBLICANS.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
AN ARGUMENT, YOU GO AFTER THE
PERSON.
THAT'S ALWAYS WHAT YOU SEE WITH
MORNING BLOW.
THEY ARE QUITE POSSIBLY THE
DUMBEST PEOPLE ON TELEVISION.
TOGETHER THEY CAN GET ONE BRAIN
CELLS ACTUALLY I'M DOING EXACTLY
WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE DISCUSSION
IS IN A LOT OF POLITICAL
DISCUSSIONS YOU ARE CONDEMNED IF
YOU HAVE TWO THOUGHTS IN YOUR
HEAD.
YOU MUST HAVE A SINGLE VARIABLE
THOUGHT, RIGHT?
IT'S LIKE THE DEMS CAN ONLY
SCREAM "IT'S GUNS."
BUT THE REPUBLICANS MIGHT JUST
SAY IT'S THE PERPETRATOR WHEN
ACTUALLY THESE VARIABLES CAN
INTERSECT.
YOU CAN SAY THE PERSON
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS KILLING IS
THAT PERSON.
BY HAVING THAT RIFLE MADE HIM
MORE EFFECTIVE.
SHOULD WE DISCUSS THAT?
SHOULD WE TRY TO TEST A BAN.
GERALDO HAS BROUGHT IT UP A
BUNCH OF TIMES AND IT'S BEEN
AROUND FOR A WHILE A WHILE.
RAISING THE AGE FROM 18 TO 21.
I DON'T SEE IT AS THOROUGHLY
IRRATIONAL.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU PUT AN
EXPIRATION DATE ON IT SO YOU CAN
COMPARE THREE YEARS OR FIVE
YEARS OF IT.
WHY NOT ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES.
IT'S LIKE THESE VIDEOS WILL BE
LOOKED AT GEORGE FLOYD AND OTHER
PEOPLE IN THESE POLICE
ENCOUNTERS.
WE GET THERE WHEN IT'S OVER AND
THEN WE PICK IT APART.
WE ACT LIKE WE ARE THE EXPERTS.
THESE SPECTACLES, EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE NOT RARE ENOUGH, THEY
ARE RARE ENOUGH THAT WE CAN
ANALYZE EACH ONE THE WAY YOU CAN
ANALYZE THOSE VIDEOS AND YOU
WILL YIELD SOME COMMON THREAD,
WHETHER IT'S UNTREATED MENTAL
ILLNESS, WHETHER IT'S BULLYING,
BROKEN HOMES, LACK OF SECURITY,
MEDIA AMPLIFICATION WHICH
HAPPENS TO BE MY THING THAT I
TALK ABOUT ALL THE TIME.
I DON'T THINK IT'S RIGHT TO KEEP
DOING THIS ALL THE TIME.
BUT YOU CAN COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS IF YOU DECIDE TO
ENTERTAIN MORE THAN ONE
VARIABLE.
NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT YOU
SHOWED ARE CAPABLE OF
ENTERTAINING MORE THAN ONE
VARIABLE.
THEY ARE STUCK IN ONE ROUTE AND
THEY WILL NEVER GET OUT OF IT.
WE ARE ABLE HERE ON "THE FIVE"
TO DISCUSS THESE THINGS.
WE CAN DISCUSS IT AND DISAGREE.
THEY ARE INCAPABLE.
>> Jesse: I'M WONDERING IF THE
MEDIA MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IN WASHINGTON TO
COMPROMISE WITH REPUBLICANS TO
DO A DEAL.
>> Katie: I THINK SO.
FULL DISCLOSURE, I DO MENIAL
WORK AND I AM A LONGTIME SECOND
AMENDMENT ADVOCATE.
IT DOES MAKE IT HARDER FOR
DEMOCRATS WHO WANT TO COME TO
THE TABLE HAVE A REAL ADULT
CONVERSATION AS YOU WOULD SAY
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
THE ARROGANCE THAT WE HAVE SEEN
FROM THE MEDIA, THE MAJORITY OF
THEM, THE IGNORANCE WE HAVE SEEN
FROM THEM, THEY SCOFF AND IGNORE
AND MAKE FUN OF REAL EXPERTS OUT
IN AMERICA WHO UNDERSTAND WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO GO AND BOLSTER
SCHOOL SAFETY, WHO HAPPENED TO
BE PART OF THE FIREARMS
COMMUNITY, WHO KNOW WHAT THEY
ARE DOING KIDS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY SAFE.
BECAUSE THEY MIGHT BE NRA
MEMBERS ARE BECAUSE THEY OWNED
FIREARMS, THEY ARE IGNORED AND
THEREFORE THE PROBLEM IS NEVER
SOLVED.
I'VE SEEN A FEW THINGS.
THE 21 AGE LIMIT GOT SHUT DOWN
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE ISSUE OF MENTAL HEALTH, THIS
GUY REPORTEDLY CUT HIS FACE ON
HIS OWN.
THAT IS SOMETHING SOMEONE SHOULD
GO TO AN INSTITUTION.
IF YOU FILL OUT A BACKGROUND
CHECK, YOU ASK AND IF YOU'VE
ANSWERED HONESTLY IF YOU'VE BEEN
PUT INTO A MENTAL INSTITUTION
AND IF YOU SAY YES, YOUR
BACKGROUND CHECK SHOULD FAIL.
HE PASSED THAT BACKGROUND CHECK.
POLITICIANS WHO SAY THAT WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING TO DO SOMETHING
WHEN THEY KNOW IT WON'T WORK AND
TELL PEOPLE IT WILL WORK.
THAT'S NOT PRODUCTIVE.
THAT'S LYING.
THAT'S DISHONEST.
WORK ON STUFF THAT WILL SOLVE
THE PROBLEM AND LISTEN TO REAL
EXPERTS, NOT 99% OF THE MEDIA
WHO HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> Jesse: IF YOU FILL OUT A
BACKGROUND CHECK AND YOU JUST
LIE LIKE HUNTER BIDEN DID, IF
THAT IS AN EFFECTIVE BACKGROUND
CHECK.
>> Harold: AUSTRALIA HASN'T
HAD ONE MASS SHOOTING SINCE
1996.
THEY PLACED PUBLIC SAFETY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH OVER SOME OF THE
THINGS.
THEY PRIORITIZED IT DIFFERENTLY
THAN WE HAVE.
KATIE, I WOULD DIFFER WITH YOU
ON SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
SHARED.
I DON'T DIFFER WITH YOU ON YOUR
PASSION AND COMMITMENT TO GUN
SAFETY.
BUT THINK ABOUT THIS, IN MOST
STATES YOU HAVE TO HAVE HUNDREDS
OF HOURS OF TRAINING TO CUT
SOMEONE'S HAIR TO GET A LICENSE
FOR THIS YOUNG MAN IN TEXAS
BARELY WAS ABLE TO GET AN AR-15
WITH NO TRAINING.
I SHARE THE DATA POINT A FEW
MINUTES AGO.
3,448 DAYS, 900 SHOOTINGS.
I THINK WE SHOULD PUT IT ALL ON
THE TABLE.
I TRIED MY HARDEST WHEN I WAS IN
CONGRESS TO WORK WITH
REPUBLICANS, LIBERAL DEMOCRATS,
CONSERVATIVE DEMOCRATS.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
MORE RESOURCE OFFICERS IN
SCHOOLS.
I WENT TO DATE NEAR MY KIDS
SCHOOLS, TWO ARMED GUYS LOOK
LIKE THEY WERE NAVY SEALs
OUTSIDE THAT SNEAKERS STORE.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
WHEREWITHAL, THE RESOURCES,
EVERYONE HAS TO COME TO THE
TABLE AND FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE WE
NOT DOING TO SECURE AND MAKE OUR
SCHOOL SAFE?
OUR SCHOOLS.
JUDGE, YOU AND I.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT POLICE
OFFICERS AND POLICE DEPARTMENTS
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
PROTOCOL IS WHEN THEY GO TO THE
SCHOOLS.
WE SHOULD NOT AS PARENTS COME TO
A SCHOOL AND WONDER WHO'S IN
CHARGE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING?
THAT IS THEIR JOB.
SO MANY THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
PUT ON THE TABLE AND I WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU IN THIS REGARD,
GUNS IS NOT THE ONLY THING.
WE ARE FOOLS IF WE DON'T BELIEVE
WE HAVE TO HAVE A SERIOUS
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW STEPS,
REASONABLE AND SENSIBLE STEPS
THAT WE CAN TAKE FROM PUBLIC
SAFETY TO DEAL WITH GUNS.
>> Judge Jeanine: ONE OF THE
THINGS ABOUT GUNS IS THAT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT CHICAGO, I MEAN,
THAT IS JUST A FACT.
GUNS ARE ILLEGAL IN CHICAGO.
CHICAGO HAS MORE KILLINGS THAN
WE SEE ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE
COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE ONE EVERY WEEKEND.
KIDS DON'T EVEN RUN AT THE SOUND
OF A GUN.
THEY WANT TO MAKE THIS ILLEGAL,
THAT ILLEGAL.
BUT HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
NEW YORK CITY WAS ONCE THE
SAFEST LARGE CITY, NOT THAT LONG
AGO, IN THE UNITED STATES.
THE REASON WE ARE NOT SAFE
ANYMORE, THE REASON CRIME IS
SURGING IS NOT BECAUSE OF AN
INCREASE -- IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF
COVID.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC.
IT'S BECAUSE THE SAME PEOPLE AND
THEIR SOCIAL JUSTICE AGENDA HAVE
DECIDED WE'D GOT TO LET
EVERYBODY OUT ON BAIL.
LET'S NOT KEEP ANYBODY IN JAIL,
EVEN IF WE THINK THEY ARE A
DANGER, EVEN IF THEY HAVE A GUN,
LET'S LET THEM OUT WITH A GUN.
AND IN THE END, LET'S DEMORALIZE
AND DEFUND THE POLICE.
WHO IS AT RISK?
THE BLACK, BROWN PEOPLE?
ALL OF THE MINORITIES ARE AT
RISK.
THIS IS ALL POLITICS AND THE
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM WE HAVE IN
THIS COUNTRY IS THAT THE
POLITICIANS WANT TO FIGHT WITH
EACH OTHER.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SOLVE
ANYTHING.
THEY COULD SOLVE ISSUES LIKE
IMMIGRATION.
THEY COULD SOLVE ISSUES HAVING
TO DO WITH GUNS.
KATIE IS RIGHT.
THE NINTH CIRCUIT CAME DOWN
INSIDE YOU CANNOT TELL US HOW
OLD SOMEBODY HAS TO BE TO BUY A
GUN.
THAT'S THE NINTH CIRCUIT.
THE NINTH CIRCUIT IN CALIFORNIA.
DO YOU KNOW HOW LIBERAL THEY
ARE?
LET'S JUST GET TOGETHER AND
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE
ONLY LOOKING FOR THE NEXT
ELECTION.
>> Harold: FOR THE WHITE GUY.
>> Jesse: SPEAK FOR YOURSELF,
HA